it's great to welcome to the program
today bill Bostock who's a news reporter
at Business Insider based in London
focusing specifically on the Middle East
he broke the report on the Saudi
government app Absher which was recently
condemned by many American lawmakers for
allowing Saudi men to track and monitor
where women travel bill pleasure to have
you on really appreciate it Thanks so
how did this app originally sort of get
on your radar well it's been the apps
been around for a few years what really
got at my radar was at people when we
are we've sort of we're thing on earth
Inc these old messages saying that they
were getting alerts from the app telling
their legal guardians that they would
leave in the country this may be women
obviously and children so that's what
brought it back into into the public
domain the app was basically kept
getting better and it is actually a very
efficient tool like we would be pretty
shocked with it we had in states or in
the UK so basically is just like it came
back on the radar and suddenly people
were raising questions with people that
hosted apps like Apple in Google
yeah and so I want to talk about the the
perspective of those the app stores on
which that this app exists because on
the one hand it's undeniable that in
practice this is being used in a way
that by our standards curtails the the
the rights of significant groups of
people including women on the other hand
within the context of Saudi Arabian law
it correct me if I'm wrong it's not
actually breaking any laws right so
where does that leave the Apple Apple
Store and the Google Play Store yes
basically the crux having his eyelids
gone for two months now and that is
basically wherever hat with the crust it
doesn't break any laws women have
Guardians who act like normal normal men
and do not restrict their movement in
Saudi Arabia so for many people the
guardianship system doesn't really apply
and instead they say break any laws I'm
amazing smooth and efficient but the
question I think that bright
foods through an apple and google as
we're trying to get saudi arabia to a
point where they don't have a
guardianship system and indeed Mohammed
bin Salman has hinted when he was
interviewed by the Atlantic last year
that he would be reforming the system so
I think what rights groups were arguing
is that this is time for Apple and
Google to take a stand and I think into
using words Senator Ron Wyden he said
this this apps and flies in the face of
the society you both tried to defend or
claim to defend so the Apple and Google
Crist ISM I think was warranted in terms
of the evidence that was presented by me
and by other people what happened in
Google now have chosen not to do is
indeed as you say treat this in Western
standards again doesn't break any laws
the case it's been compared to it is of
the Living Hope Ministries Act which was
a gay conversion therapy app which has
been taken down after that because that
was demonstrably detrimental to people's
well-being so they're a bit they can't
prove that it seems that this is one of
those cases where I'm speculating here
but maybe Google and Apple believe that
if there's not any criminality that the
a political decision is not to remove
the app but I think what's missing from
that analysis is that ignoring the
ignore allowing the app to remain is in
a sense an implicit political act right
I mean either way there's sort of a
political consideration and a
public-relations consideration and a
human rights consideration but simply
taking the position that if it's not
illegal we're not removing it that is a
very political position to take in and
of itself massively apps being
immediately politicized by groups and
you know every app could easily have its
own how its intended to pick you know
Facebook is incredibly damaging for a
lot of people you know a lot of horrible
content we share on YouTube you know you
can't blame a brick wall to graffiti
some people said but yeah in sense they
are being passive
letting it roll over I can't
I know basically there is a personal
relationship between sundar pichai at
Google and MBS I think in a business I
think just totally in a business way
they he did give almost an Tim Cook's
work and they MBS is taking a tour of
the Apple HQ in them California so yes
they are being political they are
washing their hands of the issue and
setting a precedent for I mean basically
those out there hands if you use an app
that you know what happens on there is a
problem is it fair to assume and if it's
not it would be extraordinarily
important to know is it fair to assume
that if the same app what was related to
a different group than women in Saudi
Arabia under surveillance if it was some
particular group in the United States if
it was an app for you know whatever you
we can imagine what it is is it
abundantly clear that Google and Apple
would handle it differently or is there
some gray area there the bay area you I
think that applying size fits all to
these apps never works and that's you
know and Twitter have found that with
just their treating user policy you like
it's just is you're never going to
please everyone yeah I mean I can't say
any more than I think that they will
just wash our hands of this and they um
they don't know what to do they're just
gonna wait and see I sort of hesitate to
even bring this up but I'm curious you
know we we know about what happened to
Jamal Khashoggi once is sort of critical
reporting about Saudi Arabia started and
not to make the reporting on this app
equivalent there were many other broader
sort of political considerations every
situation is unique and different
there's no question about that but have
you received any kind of feedback
through direct or indirect channels
about your reporting on this do you have
any concerns for what the the blowback
might be to your reporting about this
issue dissident and critic of the state
and being Saudi says
afford a different treatment I think
there are a few things like Twitter
trolls and email spam and I did once
wake up and my my Twitter account was in
Arabic but I'm sure that was just an
accident
but in it I feel fine I mean the the
social media coordinator I'm gonna call
it a coordinate system so there are
coordinated attempts with every negative
news story about Saudi Arabia and I know
that like several large organizations in
the United States have noticed this that
I've spoken to you that usually with
stuff like the khashoggi case weird
stuff like am sure there are like a
mobilized army online who will try and
boost the reviews an app from Google
Play I think resource 12,000 single
reviews of the app shot on Google Play
in one day
most of them duplicates so yeah there's
like a definite presence that like there
are people who the world they may not be
connected to the government and
officially do support the position of
the government and then we'll let you
know online by whatever means they feel
good so let me sort of play devil's
advocate I guess as far as the the
specifics of the app for a second what
would you say if someone wants to argue
and again this is not my argument but I
think it's worth sort of just exploring
this is an app that makes it easier for
Saudi women to leave their homes not
accompanied by a male relative right and
that in a sense there's a net advantage
to well the old situation was even worse
in Saudi Arabia with the app yes they
are they are monitored yes they are
tracked but it is a margin it's a it's a
slightly higher degree of autonomy in a
sense and maybe that should be seen as a
good thing rather than bad what would
you say to such an argument yeah
fantastic point I've thought that many
times yes the app does make life easier
it has taken out you know there was a
viral video so taking what it was like
queuing at the passport office before
Absa and it was it was a scrum it was a
scrum which line it was insane so yes I
would agree it does make it easier
whether that ease justified
is the digitization of a very impressive
thing which is therefore to require
women to get commissioned to travel and
indeed many other things not included on
the app the guardianship system we're
talking about
that's tricky I think personally that
several that though I mean that that
feature should be removed on principle
because it is ask imagery and like like
notably so yeah playing devil's like as
you say that's a big I mean why a lot of
women even say they like yeah it's made
it much easier and but the majority of
people you only live in metropolitan
areas from my understanding of what the
case for the rural areas they're not
experiencing the same liberation at the
app has given any people living in
cities in Saudi Arabia yeah I mean I
guess it comes down to if we imagine
some path towards longer-term reform in
Saudi Arabia do we believe that the sort
of making more convenient and digitizing
as you say of some of the oppression
that currently exists is that going to
in the big picture get us closer to
progress or is it simply going to enable
sort of more technologically slick means
of preserving it I don't know the answer
and I don't know that any of us really
do know so the absolute rollout will
continue and incorporate eventually all
of the Saudi government services which
you know becomes interesting because
well we have an incredibly free civic
life in the West and we don't have
something like absurd for example that
we do in a way give a lot to governments
and companies in terms of data so that
we are I think both moving towards the
same outcome which is like a very close
relationship between the state
technology and personal data yeah it
seems in Saudi Arabia that like this is
a part of a process which is ongoing and
will keep going and you know in fairness
I oversee narrator is one there's
technologically progressive countries in
the world in terms of sort of consumer
technology more smartphone years users
per capita
so the thing that I know in the world
yeah and it will keep going
absolutely fantastic report reporting on
this issue we've been speaking with bill
Bostock who's a news reporter at
Business Insider based in London
focusing in on the Middle East bill
really a pleasure having you on today I
appreciate your time